now that was scary collision on a busy
canal in Venice Italy its leading to new
calls to ban giant cruise ships from the
area this take a look at this it was the
chaotic scene yesterday when a cruise
ship lost control crashing into a
riverboat and a crowded dock five people
were hurt in that accident Seth Doane is
at the canal in Venice where the
accident happened Seth how are people
locally reacting good morning Tony many
people are saying enough is enough this
has really really - this controversy
that's been going on here for years in
Venice where we've heard many residents
and activists saying these ships are
simply too big for this fragile city
the massive ship just would not stop on
the dock people fled as the towering 13
deck high vessel its horn blaring
grinded into a much smaller boat and the
site of the pier the cruise liner which
holds more than 2600 people had reported
mechanical difficulties as it came into
port Sunday morning
and the tugboats trying to guide it in
safely were not strong enough just to
see this thing out of control was just
almost literally unbelievable five
people were injured Sunday while many in
Venice filled the city itself was
already wounded by these ships protests
sparked immediately it worries me
because it's something that could have
happened so many other times and could
happen again today Jane D'Amato is an
environmental scientist who heads we are
here Venice which wants to ban cruise
ships she worries they endanger the
fragile Lagoon dwarf the city and change
its character the cruise ships bring a
huge number of people concentrated into
the city and they've acted like kind of
the icebreaker for the destruction of
Venice through mass tourism wrongs of
tourists are drawn to the picturesque
canals of this former maritime Republic
cruise ships alone bring in about two
million visitors a year Banksy the
street artist whose identity is not
known recently added his flourish to the
protests following Sunday mornings crash
Venice's mayor said once again it's
shown that big ships cannot cross the
do-deca canal and Italy's Transport
Minister tweeted that the country here
is close to finding a solution to
protect both the city its Lagoon and
tourism Gale says Don thank you and may
we point out that says Don was on
vacation in Venice yes and then he gets
the call thank you very much set I hope
we're paying for his vacation now I'm
happy to do as many of these stories and
venice's as you and the rest of us
really appreciate what you're doing
thank you so much